in eSports there stories of prodigies oh
thank heroes who have triumphs
thanks to their undying love of the game
and players that proved their doubters
wrong through hard work and skill alone
while all the faced adversity in their
quests for greatness
none have earned the title of the
greatest and willingly chosen to walk
away from it none except for zero
universally recognized as the best
player of our time for smash work but
the story of the king of smash 4 isn't
made of happy memories zeroes throne is
a lonely one sitting in a kingdom built
on a foundation of torment years of hard
work and a role he never wanted the
villain of someone else's story even
people that I quill consider my friends
actually warm Italy zeros rain was
incredible but the path he took to get
to the top was greater still this is his
story
Gonzalo zero Barrios was born on April
17th 1995 Incheon Chile he started
playing smash in 1999 at the age of four
when the original Super Smash Brothers
released on the Nintendo 64 but zero had
a difficult childhood I pretty much from
the very beginning I saw the ugly side
of many things a few things happen you
know very very awful experience happened
we're like ok I like everything shatter
you know so so then my parents you know
we're not together anymore the sense of
family was destroyed you know I didn't
have a stable home for like the majority
of my childhood I was pretty much in
poverty you know for a long period of
time you know after his parents divorce
his mother was unable to find steady
work and while his family's financial
struggles may have taken a toll on him
the bullying he experienced at school
was worse still in school I was always
that the fat kid that no one really gave
a [ __ ] about you know that ass honest
you know men don't don't carry you know
like whatever I thought or whatever I
thought about anything they never could
you know I was always quiet because
people always told me to shut up zero
ended up dropping out of school but he
found refuge in a Gamecube his mother
bought him after spending countless
hours in front of a TV playing super
smash brothers melee zero decided it was
time to test his skill against others
zero attended his first melee tournament
in 2006 but didn't actually play in it I
just couldn't
I just couldn't play I just I turn
around I told my mom let's go home I'm
too nervous
eventually zero would not only overcome
his fear of competition but grow to love
the thrill of it from there CIRA was
hooked he started going to more
tournaments and when he wasn't competing
he worked picking blueberries with his
mother so that he could afford to go to
even more smash events he began
dominating the local Chilean scene
first in melee then in a sequel Super
Smash Brothers Brawl he discovered that
in America people like melee legend ken
ken Wong and halo champion Tom T squared
Taylor were making a living as
professional video game players in 2011
Xero picked up his first recorded
tournament victory 1st place in Chile's
second national brawl tournament after
repeated successes on home soil zero
realized that it was time to take his
talents to America zeros first-ever
international event was apex 2012 where
he placed 17th in singles and 9th in
doubles the policing that low wasn't
enough to make a living on zero return
to Chile but the promise of being able
to live off smash like others were doing
was intoxicating in 2013
Xero asked his mother to let him go to
the United States for one year to try
and make a career out of smash if he
couldn't do it he'd go back home maybe
go to college and leave the game behind
for good
Zera moved to philadelphia and began to
eke out a living he would practice brawl
compete in tournaments and use the money
he earned to pay his friends family some
rent for letting him stay in their
basement in fact that anyway charged me
anything for the first few months
because they wanted me to get a foot on
the ground pretty much and kind of like
start making some money and then they
and then they charged me a little bit
they pretty much charge me like what
like $200 a month you know just to live
there each month you know which was
extremely generous you know everything
else was reinvested into smash so that
he could attend more tournaments he
spent hours on buses going from
Philadelphia to New York to New Jersey
to California to Maryland all well
studying videos of top Brawl players to
find weaknesses in their game and his
studies pay it off zero turned heads
with wins over some of brawls best
players
Dishman with a really deep offstage and
that could cost them through with a
hedge guard oh my gosh in private
mew2king told him he had what it took to
become one of the best over the next
while zero competed at placed and a
myriad of tournaments and in time his
wins began outpacing his rent
however despite being successful enough
to no longer worry about making a living
zero never established himself as a
dominant force in Brawl on the level
that mew2king and IRA were but then he
got his big break at e3 2013 Nintendo
unveiled Super Smash Brothers for 3ds
and Wii U with serious creator Masahiro
Sakurai saying that the game would fall
somewhere between the pace of melee and
brawl for e3 2014 just a few months
ahead of the game's launch Nintendo held
an invitational tournament with some of
Smash's biggest names including zero
with the world watching the zero didn't
waste his opportunity
and we have
the body - you get off of a went in
those conditions is inexplicable like it
is the kind of body high that I can be
80 years old and I don't remember that
because it was it was that impactful
like I would say it is one of the best
moments I have ever lived in my
existence sure the event didn't exactly
play by official tournament rules but
his grand finals win over hungrybox put
zero on the map zero kept playing melee
and brawl up to smash for his release
but smash 4 called to him at Sky smash 4
Invitational the first tournament to be
played with competitive rules 0 placed
third after that there was no stopping
him first at UGC bi-weekly triumph or
Die 24 smash we super smash satyrs you
see by double Vegas down at skill con
USC smaller uses a clash online and
couple Vegas down a title banished for
roaches apex 25th showdown cybers of the
gaming shop after double Vegas down come
on and back out regionals 20mpg so tigey
to an iron dice smash for Lilian turning
ire and I we smash for lire Vegas down a
tire into combo breakers best 25th up on
Vegas down a parody Zeo 20 FCC smash
levo 20 MSS 1 top cut comics and Popa 43
tournaments into the longest win streak
in eSports history zero was signed by
Team solomid and he wasn't done yet
between November 2014 and October 2015
at 0 won an unprecedented 53 tournaments
in a row
53 tournaments in 11 months 0 wasn't
just winning a few big tournaments and
ignoring the rest he was grinding out
more than a tournament a week all over
the United States if you had a local 0
was willing to make the trip and take
your money - and he wasn't just winning
he was dominating yet again take it
another youth tournament he wasn't just
the best he was unbelievable graphic
that's gonna be a hero all the way from
losers
keeping his brain perhaps his most
impressive individual feet came at Evo
2015 when zero became the first smash
player to ever win the tournament
without dropping a single game back in
his glory days Ken the man Xero hooked
up to at the beginning of his career was
known as the king of smash zero became
the first person to ever truly inherit
that title but when you're the king you
will always face a challenge to your
crown and an MLG New Orleans naira would
bring zeros incredible streak to a
dramatic
[Applause]
despite losing his air of invincibility
zero bounced back proving why he had
reigned for so long this percent there
are no guaranteed fifty fifties it all
comes down to whether taxes cut Bradley
but after 64 recorded first place
finishes in just over a year an injury
forced him onto the side even during his
hiatus zero was ranked as the greatest
mass for player in the world but two
months was a long time to go without
real practice and it started to look
like his opposition was beginning to
catch up zero finally returned to
competition in Canada and get on my
level 2016 where he managed to place
second it was an incredible showing for
someone who hadn't played seriously in
two months but zeros results were going
to remain inconsistent second a 2gg team
Mexico saga second at smashing splash to
3-1 9th at CEO his first time missing
top eight in two years third at what the
Fox to dropping yet another third at evo
2016 and zero hit his lowest point yet
with 13th and super smash con 2016 the
story for a lot of people going in here
was can 0 get the streak back can he put
himself back on top and unfortunately
the answer is no 0 was beating solid
players but losing to lower ranked are
at the time unknowns people were ready
to write him off but he triumphed at
endgame in Illinois beating Evo champion
Ally and crushing mew2king
with a perfect jv3 stock in ran not over
yet folks
oh my god 0 1 shine 2016 the next week
without dropping a single cent a
performance reminiscent of his dominant
era but again his
dipped zero took a fall in March 2017
finishing 49th at to GGC Civil War his
lowest placing ever after that he only
missed top eight twice and brought home
31 first-place trophies including wins
at CEO dreamland to GGC Neera saga CEO
and shine 2017 zero achieved everything
he wanted to do when he left Chile he
was the absolute best player smash4 had
ever seen there was no one left to beat
nothing left to conquer I wanted to beat
everybody I wanted to beat every single
character every single player you know I
wanted to beat the best players in the
pen the best players from every state
I just wanted to build something that I
felt was unshakable that I felt I will
be so satisfied with that I could just
turn the page on it and then look back
at it and say I did all that work for
that
I built something that I'm proud of the
same day he announced his retirement
zero was ranked first again even at the
very end he was still the best player in
the world from the height of his
dominant streak to the inconsistent days
of placing outside of top a zero earned
every win every triumph and every bit of
praise he received zero started from
nothing but by dedicating himself to
smash through making it his life he
found success you know even if I have
the worst loss of all time even if I
have liked even if I feel like the game
sucks you know even if whatever reason I
feel like at the moment you know I still
always come back to a nice always enjoy
it I still always makes me feel the most
out of anything
zero went from no one to one of eSports
best from a poor kid in Chile to the
king of smash 4 he scrounged by on
tournament winnings never underestimated
his opponents and always studied always
practiced for the next fight my goal was
never to like make money with this or be
popular and I just hope other people
that maybe my position you know just
somebody looks at it and says hey if
this person with salt a few resources
could manage to do all this they'll get
this far maybe I can do it too with
anything regardless of whether zero
returns one day to dominate as he did
over the last few years nothing can take
away from his legacy and the obstacles
he overcame along the way to attain it
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]